qui ont marqué des points pendant cette
campagne qualificative on pense
évidemment à certains joueurs qui
avaient raté de peu la coupe du monde
notamment kingsley koeman qui a vraiment
fait des bonnes des bonnes prestations
de l'absence de qui viennent demba p cet
automne il ya aussi lucas digne qui a
plutôt fait des bons matches sur le côté
gauche en l'absence de lukas hernandez
wissam ben yedder qui avait aussi raté
la coupe du monde qui a qui a marqué des
points même si hier à tirana il l'a pas
fait il n'a pas fait un gros match
il ya aussi des joueurs qui étaient qui
sont champions du monde mais qui avait
un statut de remplaçant et qui ont
marqué des points on pense forcément à
corentin tholy sow qui en l'absence de
paul pogba et de n golo quand t'es fait
des belles prestations au milieu de
terrain
de quoi mettre le doute dans la tête de
didier deschamps il lui envoie sûrement
un message en lui disant qu'il a
peut-être un statut autre que celui de
remplaçant parmi les joueurs qui ont
marqué des points on pense aussi et
surtout à clément l'anglais clément
l'anglais ses premières sélections en
andorre au mois de juin
titulaire indiscutable au fc barcelone
il a montré de très belles choses avec
l'équipe de france en l'absence de
samuel umtiti son coéquipier au barça
mais qui est souvent blessé
voilà il s'est déjà installé un peu
comme un comme un taulier en quelques
mois ce qui est assez surprenant malgré
son erreur assez grossière contre la
moldavie au stade de france
il a marqué beaucoup de points en vue de
l'euro il ya aussi une confirmation
pendant ces éliminatoires c'est
qu'antoine griezmann c'est bien le
patron des bleus
on l'a vu vraiment au leader pendant
toute cette campagne sa dernière
prestation en albanie hier soir l'a
encore prouvé c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment le taulier de ces bleus même
s'il connaît des difficultés à barcelone
en équipe de france il se sublime
toujours antoine griezmann parmi les
joueurs qui ont perdu des points alors
c'est un peu paradoxal parce qu'il est
toujours titulaire il marque des buts on
pense à olivier giroud qui a été buteur
en islande qui a remarqué aussi contre
la moldavie sur penalty en comme en
islande mais son statut en club fait que
sont sa position un petit peu fragilisé
chez les bleus puisque didier deschamps
le dit et le répète il faut jouer en
club pour pouvoir prétendre à une place
dans le groupe des 23
voilà olivier giroud il joue quasiment
plus à chelsea il est vraiment dans une
situation difficile il va devoir sans
doute partir cet hiver pendant le
mercato pour aller gagner du temps de
jeu c'est vraiment le point
d'interrogation de ce groupe parmi les
champions du monde parmi ceux qui ont
perdu des points on pense aussi à
ousmane dembélé qui n'a pas joué une
seule minute en bleu
en 2019 ousmane dembélé champion du
monde mais qui a du mal à s'imposer au
fc barcelone pour diverses raisons
notamment beaucoup de blessures
voilà il a un talent immense il lui
reste six mois encore pour revenir dans
les petits papiers de didier deschamps